hello my name is Anita Narayan doorknob
I am a senior lecturer in mechanical
engineering from Michigan Technological
University in my presentation I'll
demonstrate how specific enthalpy of
steam can be approximated using neural
networks
morning and thank you for joining me for
my presentation which is approximating
steam properties machine learning on the
ia PWS standard the title field did not
allow more than these many characters
which is why it was so abbreviated just
just so that you know the ia PWS is the
International Association of properties
of water and steam they are actually an
international standards organization
that publish the properties of water for
a living right and steam obviously so
that's what my presentation is generally
about so let me briefly talk about what
I'm doing and where I'm from who i am i
am a senior lecturer in mechanical
engineering engineering mechanics at
Michigan Technological University from
the Upper Peninsula of Michigan that's
the part of the United States that's
left out in a lot of maps sometimes or
coupled with Wisconsin for whatever
reason so I had to find a map that shows
that as a separate entity as part of
Michigan it's a very beautiful place and
these two images that you see of our
seasons are just two days apart
not really but they are two seasons that
so the season on the left-hand side the
summer is very very short its June July
ish let's just say that we tackle about
300 to 325 inches of snow every year and
barely do we ever have cancellations of
school maybe twice in the last 13 years
so it's a it's actually a fantastic
place to be if you're into technology
and if you wish to either study or work
at a top-class University honestly so so
this really is a machine learning
opportunity in traditional
thermodynamics pedagogy right
thermodynamics teaching I am NOT what
I'm not going to do here is revolutional
eyes how we use steam tables no it's
it's it's a perfectly fantastic way as
to how to use steam tables that we have
right now I'm not Ravel utilizing that
necessarily you could consider that to
be the case depending on your use case
but primarily the opportunity from my
point of view that I'm uncovering since
I teach thermodyne
Amyx is how can I roll machine learning
into an engineering thermodynamics
course right without too much effort so
that mechanical engineering students who
are predominantly from a non machine
learning background right so mechanical
engineering students when they exit this
course they understand more than just
the vocabulary of machine learning and
neural networks so what I have in this
image is how there is a decision tree
approach if you will on how you
triangulate or interpolate the
properties of steam all right you need
to first know the state of steam in
terms of either the temperature and
pressure temperature and quality or
whatever it is essentially we need two
properties of state at Amana and from
there we make a decision on where
exactly are we are we saturated liquid
saturated vapour superheated and so on
and consult a table using that kind of a
decision tree and extract properties
that's that's the classical way that's
the canonical approach of steam tables
in thermodynamics right and that's
fantastic what the mathematical neural
networks and the advanced rather the
automated machine learning framework
allows is for introducing machine
learning into the habitat of mechanical
engineering thermodynamics so if I am
able to introduce machine learning into
the habitat of mechanical engineering
thermodynamics I have a much better
chance a lower activation energy if you
will of having students understand what
machine learning is in a sense demystify
machine learning and neural networks for
non computing students mostly right
because no doubt there exist a lot of
examples you know the C Farsi for 10 the
the the NIST M nest rather handwritten
digits and so on fantastic examples for
neural networks classification
what-have-you but they are not in the
appropriate habitat if you will for
mechanical engineering students so this
is my effort to bring that into our
curriculum one of the many examples so
what I'm trying to do here is to use the
automated machine learning function
product
the neural network function net rain to
approximate the specific enthalpy of
steam to do that I train my neural
network specifically on the highly
accurate data that is available from the
International Association of properties
of water and steam right and this plot
over here is pretty much the pressure
temperature diagram as defined by the ia
PWS right what is interesting about this
plot is the the standard that they have
published sequences thermodynamic data
particularly Gibbs and Helmholtz free
energy functions I think what they are
into five major zones based on what your
temperature and pressure tuples if you
will are now based on which zone are
based on the zone that you are in or the
state of steam is in you could have an
equation of state for that particular
region for G or F or H and so on and
from that equation of state you perform
so on that equation of state rather you
perform certain numerical calculations
to calculate a specific enthalpy or a
specific internal energy or a specific
entropy and so on so honestly the data
set from the ia PWS is pretty astounding
it is indeed a multi-dimensional data
set but I am only focused on the mapping
of pressure temperature to enthalpy so
it is a very small subset of that whole
data set so a data sample if you will is
what I am considering right just so that
it is amenable for a lecture lecture and
1/2 in thermodynamics to get the point
across as to what exactly is machine
learning
what is neural networks right so that's
the that's the general idea so what I
will do first is a roadmap of the
approximations that I perform in this
demo predominantly I'm using the predict
automatic automatic machine learning
function as my baseline because it's a
very easy way to get into all this
demystification process and then I move
to a heuristic perceptron neural network
HP n n I train this on the full data set
that is available to me
rather the subset as I was talking about
a single isobar of steam and then I also
train my neural network on the five or
the rather the four zones that are
clearly available from the standard and
lots and lots of comparisons are made of
one type of approximation which is
predict versus the other type of
approximation which is the neural
network so so predominantly or actually
you could consider this to be a
regression kind of a problem really
right there is some sort of a
classification thrown in but that comes
with the problem you are classifying or
clustering specific enthalpy into five
different pockets for the standard so
there is that right so let me get my
data into the notebook okay dot - yes
and I am considering a data sample if
you will which is organized into four
columns column one is my temperature in
degrees Celsius column two is my
pressure and bar column three is the
reagent specification it goes through
one two three and five region four is a
very thin slit if you will and I don't
have enough data density in this example
to capture Region four and fine and
finally column four is the specific
enthalpy of steam in kilo Joule per
kilogram so there are three more zeros
that you'd have to append to that or you
know ten to the third multiplier so
those are my columns of data and what is
interesting is that the data really you
could perform a k-means clustering of
the data and that's what it really looks
like there is a sequencing of the data
set into four zones using k-means if you
well if you specify four zones I
artificially specified four zones so
there so as to have qualitative
similarity with the actual data
sequencing part the standard so really
if I were to look at the ia PW was
clustering the standard defined
clustering of data versus my k-means
clustering there is some qualitative
similarity a key feature of the standard
the industrial standard
is there is a fold in this data if you
notice the green portion of the data has
some sort of a logistic sigmoid fold
you know spoiler alert essentially that
allows me to switch between different
layers of a neural network to better
capture that particular transition if
you will right so that is the clustering
of my data set what I'll get started
with is dividing this data set the whole
data set which has all the regions or
all the zones as I call them all
temperatures pressures and specific
enthalpy TP to etch mapping I divide
that into 75% and 25% portions the 75%
portion is pretty much my training set
if you will and the 25% portion is my
validation set the only reason I chose a
7525 division is because it seemed to
work best for this particular problem I
use a gradient boosted tree in the
automatic function predict because that
seems to be the fastest particularly in
light of a presentation time that you
usually have so let me try to run
through this takes a few seconds clearly
if you haven't opened this in a
different notebook so we'll have another
at least one or two more strategic
pauses such as this when things are
cranking and I will talk about the
general ideas behind this particular
pedagogical in this particular
pedagogics err size that I'm running why
and how I'd like a few more slides to go
forth so that our general understanding
of this problem evolves so after I
finished the gradient boosted decision
tree predict operation I look just to
see what the worst predictions are just
to see if this should be this is a
worrying aspect sometimes it is and then
I look at my error percentage error with
respect to the validation data it's
pretty bad really it is pretty bad I
mean if I have a percentage error more
than 2 or 3% I should really be annoyed
with this whole process because yeah
it's it's a bad percentage error but
keep in mind that the point here is not
to create a neural network tool that
approximates specific and
Pease yet that could definitely be the
case needs some more refinement but it
is more about students understanding
what machine learning is and using
certain critical thinking skills to
compare approximations with standards
and so on right so that's one thing I
find what is interesting is that the
worst predictions are along the band of
phase change so that's good to know
because if I'm trying to calculate phase
changes or perhaps design a turbine or
something that works through a phase
change process I should be really aware
that I have some error in my
approximation so that's good to know
this is again a pretty good exercise to
know that we know where your error
exactly situated so that's good so what
I will look at now is using what my
little predict function did I will solve
a canonical problem the state of stream
steam at the entrance and exit of a
reversible adiabatic turbine is provided
the entrance condition is superheated
steam while the exit condition if I
remember correctly 100 C 100 kPa is
saturated vapor I think and I actually
performed this calculation of how much
work is produced by this turbine per
second if you will or per unit mass of
steam I find that it's 1585 kilo Joule
per kilogram from the machine learning
prediction right if I were to use that
to calculate the work produced by a
turbine but the actual prediction is 598
excuse me the actual value rather from
the standard from the data available is
519 so there is about thrice the error
so there is an overestimation of the
predict object right so we need to make
this better definitely we need to
certainly make this better so one
thought came to my mind that to make
this better why not
partition this data that we have into
isobars lines of constant pressure
because instead of dumping all the data
at my predict object let me dump just a
single isobar and see how that makes a
difference so that is exactly what I
went about doing no I'm sorry there you
go this one too very quick because an
isobar has about 1/10 of the data
available for the entire data set and I
find that there is really not
of a difference I think variety use an
isobar just to single isobar with
respect to using my predict object on
the full data set so I thought initially
that may be an advantage using a single
isobar dividing my data into isobars and
performing my prediction but clearly
that was not so much of a great thing so
what I do next is I train now a
heuristic perceptron on the isobar and
when I train my heuristic perceptron and
the isobar heuristics so all the layers
were chosen by trial or trial and error
really it's a pretty quick process right
it's a pretty quick process and when I
look at my error for my predict object
which is automated machine learning
versus the neural network or the
heuristic perceptron on the isobar
qualitatively I would say there is not
much of a difference I would obviously
need to solve many problems to see what
kind of an impact my heuristic
perceptron did so at the at the point
both have deficiencies is what I would
say that's all I would say and go on
there are other questions that need to
be asked such as would a greater density
of data help I would think yes I would
certainly think yes that's something I
can consider for the future I also have
a data set or rather the perceptron
training on the complete data set right
so let me run this this was the one that
will take a little long so I will talk
over it as this process happens or maybe
it won't take that long my computer
seems to be much slower at home so
essentially I went about introducing
this idea into an undergraduate course
in thermodynamics keep in mind these are
undergraduate students first second
years second years mostly and the
questions I posed to them before this
exercises do you understand what machine
learning is and what neural networks are
very small a sample size I had I think
eight students here so please bear that
in mind very small sample size six out
of those eight students talked about
neural networks being Watson Google
that's what helps you give you good
search results and so keep in mind these
are very young mechanical engineering
undergraduate students right
at the end of this exercise they had a
much greater understanding that neuron
networks can be used to approximate
properties of steam now going from a
very broad hand-wavy understanding of
what machine learning and neural
networks are within a single lecture
period an example such as this could
provide them with a certain more mature
direction so that's that's a win in my
case because such examples do help they
certainly help I find that when I train
my perceptron on a single isobar versus
rather on the entire data versus a
single isobar the single isobar
definitely performs better
all these percentage errors bar the more
number of bars you have the worse your
approximation is really is what it means
so so there there seems to be some merit
and dividing my data into isobars but
it's not very useful because what is the
discretization and isobars that I would
need it's pretty painful right so what I
set out to do is instead of me
discretizing my data set into isobars
lines of constant pressure
I use the ia PW of a standard and divide
my data into five zones four zones in
this case just because of data
discretization issues and I find that
when I start training my neural network
on each of these zones the error
decreases much more for instance I have
two plots over here there is no reason
to run the whole simulation again over
here two plots the first plot is the
perceptron trained on zone one as per
the standard and the second plot at the
bottom is the predict object which was
my baseline I could already tell that by
clustering my data into thermodynamic
zones as per an industrial standard I
was able to approximate specific
enthalpy of steam far better than
training some sort of an algorithm on
all the data all the data that's
available to me so clustering does make
a difference so that's a good thing
right
I do the same thing with each of the
regions region - I think perform
spectacle
well in fact I think it was almost one
or two percent was the error since the
error bar rather the error plot starts
at five percent it's a blank plot so
yeah clustering of data into Zone two
and applying or the same perceptor on to
it was a good thing
zone three was an issue remember if you
can at the beginning of the talk I
talked about zone three having this
logistic sigmoid kind of a curve that
was not properly captured through the
use of some sort of a nonlinear
hyperbolic tangent layer in my neural
network right so obviously I didn't go
into what all the layers are but zone
three was not the best prediction as
compared to my baseline which was my
predict object so zone three was
certainly lagging over there so I
there's something that I need to improve
with zone three did the same thing with
zone five zone one two three and five
were what I was looking at zone five was
pretty fantastic but so was the baseline
predict object so so what I did was I
have four zones of data four clusters of
data each of the clusters of data a
neural network was trained on it to
approximate the specific enthalpy of
steam three out of the four zones three
out of the four clusters were pretty
good one to five percent error as a
pedagogical example that's pretty good
one of the zones I think zone three ten
percent error or so that's not very good
it's really not very good again if you
are a student you you start
understanding what kind of a thumb rule
rule of thumb by I'm using okay ten
percent error is pretty bad because I
have a pretty accurate standard if I
have to go make measurements with so why
use a neural network you see that that's
that's an important realization in
itself but nevertheless nevertheless
from a an academic perspective it was
important for me to try and improve the
predictions or my approximation and zone
three which had this fold that's the
Green Zone over here at the center and
it has a fall and what's the best way of
actually improving or changing my neural
network for someone who's a user of
neural networks not so much a developer
stack more layers this is something I
learnt in yesterday's neural net for
Catholic
in stock also if you don't know how to
find union layer stack more layers to
begin with and then try to figure out
what's going on so that's exactly what I
did I snagged an extra layer along with
switching a hyperbolic tangent layer
with a logistic sigmoid layer for zone 3
which was the worst approximation and
that did seem to make a difference
I had errors for the modified zone 3
neural network much better than what I
had previously so that that tells me
something also so so yeah that was a
little bit of a run through if you will
I really breezed through a lot of this
material on what was being done as a
summary not so much a conclusion because
there's quite a lot that can yet be done
as a summary I have a baseline automated
machine learning function in the wolfram
mathematica framework which is predicted
it's a baseline I use that as a baseline
because it is the easiest to use in a
classroom without getting bogged down by
different kinds of layers and so on it
gets people thinking about machine
learning at least I have a data set
provided by the industrial rather the
International Association of properties
of water and steam that data set also
specifies certain clusters or zones of
properties of water and steam right so I
trained my predict object on the full
data and a single ISO bar
I also have a heuristic perceptron
neural network if you will with four or
five layers which I train on the full
data on a single ISO bar and each of
these zones as proposed by the standard
and I made comparisons between one and
the other essentially so so yeah that's
that's the general idea of this
particular example the next steps really
for me are to create a tool really that
locates a given temperature and pressure
point in a certain zone and applies that
specific neural network to that
particular T and P combination to find a
specific enthalpy or approximate a
specific enthalpy another interesting
thing would be
actually cluster the specific enthalpy
date using fine clusters in Mathematica
using k-means or something pretty simple
and compare that with the international
standards definition of different zones
of steam
also to look at perhaps neural network
loss plots and stop criterion if that
makes any difference to runtime because
I don't have to wait if my loss curve
has plateaued which is what I was doing
in most of these cases wait until the
loss curve has plateaued maybe that is
not necessary right so a few
acknowledgments first one is of course
in the department chair of mechanical
engineering at Michigan Tech the
director of undergraduate studies dr.
Jeff Allen members of a group called
undergraduate curriculum for industry
4.0 this is an effort to words
introducing elements such as machine
learning and neural network and in and
really distributing them or sprinkling
them all across our mechanical
engineering curriculum because that's
usually not done you would have machine
learning or neural network as specific
courses but if you want to reinforce
these concepts with students
particularly students who come from a
generally non computing background you
need to sprinkle these examples all over
the curriculum and those examples have
to be so that they fit in the framework
of the curriculum right so this the
framework here our portion of the
framework here was engineering
thermodynamics right and a few other
folks that I wish to thank there are
lots of references that I have used
which are somewhat similar but not the
same obviously because otherwise I
wouldn't be presenting this material
there have been some there's been some
of the work and artificial neural
networks on single equation of state
kind of thermodynamic analysis what I'm
looking at is multiple equations of
state there are equations of state
changing with zones in the example I
have but these example or rather these
references are more of a single equation
of state there was one interesting aswe
paper that was designing of columns
similar kind of the the concept still
remains you're mapping a set of inputs
to an output right in this case it was
the strength of the stress for
certain loading condition and so on so
that was my presentation if you have any
questions I would be happy to answer
them thank you
[Applause]